The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Let's look
now at storyboard 25,
panels A and B.
Most of the pathways
we have studied so far in
5.07 have been catabolic--
that is, the breakdown
of molecules, usually
with the objective of producing
energy rich molecules,
such as ATP, or
reducing equivalents
that ultimately could be used
for reductive biosynthesis.
Now, we're going to turn to
anabolism, or biosynthesis.
Biosynthetic pathways are
going to require energy input,
as well as reducing equivalents.
Overall, biosynthesis is
an endergonic process.
Looking at panel B,
you can see that we're
going to start with fatty
acid and lipid biosynthesis.
Fatty acids are made
in the cytoplasm.
The mitochondrion is going
to play an important role,
however.
We'll see just how in
a couple of minutes.
Let me say a couple of things
about the mitochondrion.
First, acetyl CoA, oxaloacetate
and the NADP plus NADPH pair,
as we have described
above, cannot pass through
the mitochondrial membrane.
However, malate and citrate can.
In fact, they can go
in either direction.
Keep these points in
mind as we move ahead.
Now let's look at panel c.
We're going to break down
fatty-acid biosynthesis
into five steps.
The first step involves
getting acetyl coenzyme A
into the cytoplasm.
As I just said, acetyl CoA
cannot directly go past
the mitochondrial membrane.
To overcome this problem,
nature, quote unquote,
packages acetyl CoA as citrate,
which can easily traverse
the mitochondrial membrane.
Hence, we put acetyl CoA
into a molecule of citrate,
bring citrate out
into the cytoplasm,
and then split off the
acetyl CoA once again.
The second step
involves maintaining
oxaloacetate balance.
We just transported
a molecule of citrate
out of the mitochondrial
matrix, thus
depleting the TCA cycle of one
of its important intermediates.
The levels of all TCA
cycle intermediates
are going to drop,
including oxaloacetate.
Now think about what's
happened to the citrate
in the cytoplasm.
It was split into
oxaloacetate and acetyl CoA.
If we could send
that on oxaloacetate
back into the
mitochondrion, the TCA cycle
would be replenished,
once again.
Step two will show how
oxaloacetate finds its way back
into the mitochondrial matrix.
The third step in
fatty-acid biosynthesis
involves the synthesis
of malonyl-coenzyme A.
This molecule is made by
putting a carbon-dioxide
molecule onto the methyl
carbon of acetyl CoA
using acetyl coenzyme
A carboxylase--
an enzyme we looked at earlier
in the carboxylase module
of 5.07.
malonyl-coenzyme A is the
actual precursor to all,
but two of the carbons
in the fatty acid chain.
The fourth step in
fatty-acid biosynthesis
involves putting the
malonyl-coenzyme A
onto a very large protein on
the fatty acid synthase complex.
This large protein is called
ACP, or acyl carrier protein.
The fifth step involves
the actual reactions
of the fatty acid synthase,
sometimes called FAS.
This is a large
multi-protein complex.
These are the enzymes
by which we're
going to see the stepwise
addition of two carbon units,
up until we get to the
formation of a 16 carbon
long fatty acid
called palmitic acid.
Palmitic acid,
abbreviated 16 colon 0,
is the default fatty acid length
made by the fatty acid synthase
complex.
Let's look at panel
D. After the five step
synthesis of palmitic
acid the C16 fatty
acid can be elongated.
It can have double
bonds put into it,
and it can be branched.
We're not going to be
looking into those reactions,
but we shall be looking into
the way that either two or three
fatty acids will be placed onto
a glycerol backbone in order
to make either, a
membrane lipid that
is a diacylglyceride phosphate,
or triacylglycerides.
Triacylglycerides are our
primary storage form of energy.
We're not going to be
looking into those reactions,
but we shall be
looking at the way
that either two or
three fatty acids
can be placed onto a
glycerol backbone in order
to make either a
membrane lipid that
is a diacylglyceride phosphate,
or triacylglycerides.
Triacylglycerides are
our primary storage forms
of energy.
I'm not going to be
going over another type
of fatty-acid biosynthesis,
called polyketide biosynthesis,
but I'll encourage
you to take a look
at this pathway in the book.
Polyketide biosynthesis
is a very important source
of a host of biologically
active lipids.
Let's look at panel
E. Before we look
at a schematic of
lipid biosynthesis,
I'd like to introduce NADPH.
NADPH is going to be the source
of electrons that are used
for reductive biosynthesis.
NADPH is identical to NADH with
the exception of the phosphate
at the lower right
of the molecule,
as drawn in panel
E. This phosphate is
a molecular decoration
that's recognized
by biosynthetic enzymes.
That is, enzymes
that are looking
for a source of
reducing equivalents.
NADPH is the co-factor
that provides
those reducing equivalents.
The hydrides shown
in the blue ellipse,
at the top of the
molecule, represents
the reducing equivalents
that were going
to be used in biosynthesis.
The two main
pathways that result
in the production of
NADPH, for biosynthesis,
are the pentose
phosphate pathway,
which I'm going to deal
with in a separate lecture,
and the malic enzyme,
which I'm going
to introduce in a few minutes.
Now turn to panel
F. This schematic
shows a high-level view of
fatty-acid biosynthesis.
I think it's useful to put
fatty-acid biosynthesis
in the context of one of
our physiological scenarios.
The scenario is
eat sugar, get fat.
Put more scientifically,
this scenario
is going to show
how the sugar we eat
can end up being converted,
very efficiently, into fat.
I think that, probably, most of
us want to avoid getting fat.
But keep in mind that
converting sugar to fat
is one way of converting
energy into a very compact
and mobile form.
Let's start with
the glucose molecule
over on the left of the panel.
Starting with step one, follow
the horizontal hatched line
to the right.
The glucose passes
through glycolysis,
produces pyruvate, pyruvate
goes into the mitochondrion
and is converted to acetyl CoA.
Once again, following
the hatched line,
acetyl CoA condenses
with oxaloacetate.
This is the citrate synthase
reaction to form citrate.
Rather than progressing
further into the TCA cycle
where it would lose its
carbons as carbon dioxide,
the citrate at step two is
exported by a transporter
out into the cytoplasm.
Step three is
catalyzed by an enzyme
called ATP citrate lyase.
This enzyme splits the citrate
into acetyl CoA, which is what
we want, and leave a residue--
a molecule of oxaloacetate.
I'm not going to go through
the mechanism of this enzyme,
but I think it's worthwhile to
look back at storyboard seven,
look at the citrate
synthase reaction
and then imagine it
running backwards.
Now, it's not going to be
exactly the reverse reaction as
drawn, but at this
point in 5.07 you
should be able to look at the
cosubstrates for the reaction,
and be able to figure out how
ATP citrate lyase liberates
the oxaloacetate residue.
I'm going to come back to the
oxaloacetate, which is labeled
by a star, in a few minutes.
Keep in mind that we
have to find a way
to return oxaloacetate to the
mitochondrial matrix or else
we won't have enough
oxaloacetate to enable
the next molecule
of citrate to be
formed from an incoming
acetyl coenzyme A.
At step five we have
acetyl coenzyme A
in the cytoplasm, where we want
it for fatty-acid biosynthesis.
But we can also do other
things with this molecule.
In the last lecture,
for example,
I talked about ketone
body formation.
So look at the vertical arrow--
that is the one going up.
You can see we can
produce HMG CoA, hydroxy
methyl glutaryl
coenzyme A. Which,
as I said in the last lecture,
is a biosynthetic precursor
to, for example, cholesterol,
as well as ketone bodies.
Then, follow the
arrows through step 5A
to the deposition of cholesterol
into the plasma membrane.
Keep in mind, cholesterol is
a plasticizer of the membrane.
Therefore, it's an
essential molecule.
Now let's go back and
pick up the acetyl CoA
as it progresses through
the fatty acid synthase,
or FAS Reactions of 5B.
Acetyl CoA is built
up in eight steps
to form the 16 carbon
fatty-acid palmytate.
Following the upward
arrow, palmytate
can go on to form a
phospholipid, which
will become an integral
part of the membrane,
or it can go
horizontally, to the left,
to form a
triacylglyceride, which
will become embedded
in a lipid globule
where it can serve as a
storage depot for energy.
So at this point,
through the series
of reactions numbered
5A and 5B, we've
made the membrane plasticizer,
cholesterol, phospholipids,
which are the main
structural elements
of a biological membrane,
and a triacylglycerides,
which is our principal
energy storage molecule.
Now let's go back to the
asterisked oxaloacetate,
at step 3.
This orphaned molecule
of oxaloacetate
has to be able to get back
into the mitochondrion.
There are two pathways by
which this can happen--
4A and 4B.
Oxaloacetate is a ketone.
It can be reduced by NADH
to form the alcohol, malate.
This is the reverse
of the reaction
that we're used to
seeing in the TCA cycle.
Nevertheless, this is indeed
the thermodynamically favorable
direction for this reaction.
The malate dehydrogenase
enzyme used,
here, is closely related
to the one that's
in the mitochondrial matrix.
Keep in mind, however, that
this is the cytoplasmic version
of the enzyme.
I mentioned earlier
that malate can
go in either direction across
the mitochondrial membrane.
In this case, path 4A, malate
goes into the mitochondrian,
becomes part of the
mitochondrial malate pool,
and then the mitochondrial
malate dehydrogenase
will convert it to oxaloacetate.
And thus, we have restored
the molecule of oxaloacetate
that we borrowed from
the mitochondrial matrix.
Path 4B represents
an alternative way
to return the
oxaloacetate molecule
to the mitochondrial matrix.
4B involves the
malic enzyme, ME,
which uses NADP plus to oxidize
malate back to oxaloacetate.
In the process, NADP
plus is reduced to NADPH,
the biosynthetic precursor.
This is one of
the two major ways
that a cell produces the NADPH
that it needs for biosynthesis.
The other way to make NADPH is
the pentose phosphate pathway.
It may seem kind of useless
to have taken an oxaloacetate,
and then, by using malate
dehydrogenase convert
that oxaloacetate to malate, and
then, convert the malate back
to oxaloacetate.
But by doing this
series of reactions,
you are effectively
converting NADH to an NADPH.
And NADPH is desperately needed
for biosynthesis, as we'll see.
Lipid biosynthesis is
very NADPH intensive.
Let's look at a couple
of more details.
Decyl acetate shown
in brackets in step 4B
exists on the malic enzyme.
The enzyme facilitates
the decarboxylation
of that molecule.
Remember, oxaloacetate
is a beta keto acid.
Decarboxylation by malic enzyme,
at step 4B, produces pyruvate.
Now we can follow the pyruvate,
by the continuation of step 4B,
into the mitochondrion.
The pyruvate becomes a substrate
for pyruvate carboxylase,
which we've looked at before.
Pyruvate carboxylase will
put a CO2 back into pyruvate
and convert it
into oxaloacetate.
Pyruvate carboxylase is
an ATP requiring enzyme.
Hence, path 4B has a
finite energy requirement.
It would seem as though
this might be a problem.
Nevertheless, when a cell
is doing biosynthesis,
it usually has a lot of energy
around in the form of ATP.
So this small investment
is a good one,
in order to, first of all,
restore the oxaloacetate
balance of the mitochondria,
and secondly, keep in mind,
that 4B also gives you
an NADPH, which you
need for biosynthesis, anyway.
Let's summarize this figure.
At the upper left, we
start with glucose,
and by the hatched lines,
that glucose is converted
to citrate in the cytoplasm.
Citrate then yields
an acetyl CoA molecule
that is the precursor to
fatty acids and cholesterol.
Step two dealt with the problem
of getting oxaloacetate back
into the mitochondrion.
Remember, fatty-acid
biosynthesis
happens in the cytoplasm.
We borrowed an oxaloacetate
from the mitochondrion, hence,
we have to get it back
to where it belongs
in the mitochondrial matrix.
Paths 4A and 4B represent
alternative pathways
for getting the oxaloacetate
back where it belongs.
Once the oxaloacetate is
back in the mitochondrion,
then the next
molecule of acetyl CoA
can come in, get
converted to citrate,
and follow the hatched line
path, ultimately resulting
in synthesis of lipids.
Let's turn now to story board
26, panel A. At this point,
we have a pool of acetyl
coenzyme A in the cytoplasm.
It's now ready to start
making a fatty acid.
In the carboxylase
module, I talked
about how acetyl
CoA carboxylase is
one of the carboxylases
took an active form of CO2
and placed it onto
the methyl carbon
at the end of the acetyl
coenzyme A molecule.
The product of the
carboxylase reaction
is malonyl coenzyme
A. This carboxylase
is a biotin containing
enzyme, and requires ATP.
As I've said
earlier, malonyl CoA
is going to be the source of
all, but two of the carbons
that make up the fatty acid.
The initial fatty acid
that we're going to make
is the C16 fatty
acid, palmitate.
Palmitate will be
synthesized entirely
on the fatty acid synthase.
Let's look at panel B.
Fatty-acid synthesis
in bacteria is carried
out by a series
of enzymes that work as
discrete, or independent,
units.
Collectively, this
ensemble of enzymes
is called the fatty
acid synthase complex.
In a million cells, all of
the enzymatic activities--
the same enzymatic activities--
are present in a single, very
long peptide.
At this point, I want
to go over the chemistry
behind each of the activities
in the fatty acid synthase
complex.
One of the peptides that I
introduced, briefly, above
is called ACP, or
acyl carrier protein.
It contains assisting
sulfhydryl residue that
will attack the carbonyl
group of malonyl CoA,
forming a malonyl ACP adduct.
Keep in mind that
the product is still
a thioester with all of
the chemical properties
you would find in
acetyl coenzyme.
A The enzymatic subunit
that does this chemistry
is called MAT, or mat, for
malonyl acetyl transferase.
Another domain, shown at
the bottom of the fatty acid
synthase, has a
cysteine residue that
attacks the carbonyl
group of acetyl CoA.
This reaction is also
catalyzed by MAT.
Hence, in this case,
the MAT subunit
forms an acetyl thioester
with the fatty acid synthase.
At this point, we have a malonyl
group at the-- let's call it,
northern domain of the
fatty acid synthase,
as I've drawn it--
and an acetyl group at what
I'll call, the southern domain.
Let's look at panel
C. At this point,
the fatty acid synthase
is fully primed.
That is, it is loaded with a
malonyl group and acetyl group.
Now we can start
doing some chemistry
to join these two
groups together.
The malonyl group has a beta
keto acid functionality so
can easily lose CO2, and
generate a nucleophile that
will then go down and
attack the carbonyl group
of the acetyl residue that
is on the southern domain
of the enzyme.
This reaction results
in the acetyl group,
from the southern domain,
replacing the CO2 moiety
on the northern domain.
That is, the carbonyl group
from the southern domain
ends up covalently
attached to the CH2 group,
with the box over it,
in the northern domain.
The ketoacyl synthase, that
is KS, domain of the protein,
does this reaction.
The product of the reaction
shows a beta keto acyl group
attached to the northern domain.
Keep in mind, that
the beta keto acyl
group is attached, specifically,
to the ACL carrier protein.
The next step is catalyzed
by the ketoacyl ACP
reductase, or KR.
In this case, NADPH will
reduce the keto group
that is next to the
terminal carbon,
forming an alcohol,
specifically, beta hydroxy
acyl carrier protein, or ACP.
This beta hydroxyl four
carbon compound is now primed
for dehydration
by a dehydratase,
which removes water to form
the trans-delta-2-enoyl ACP.
This molecule is an alkyne
with the double bond
between the second and third
carbons from the thioester.
Let's turn now to storyboard 27.
The reaction continues
with enoyl reductase, ER,
which uses a second
molecule of NADPH
in order to saturate the
double bond of the enoyl ACP.
The product is a butyryl
ACP at this point,
it should be clear as
to what we've done.
We've taken two
acetyl CoA molecules
and fused them together.
In the process we've done
a number of reductions,
and the product is
a pure hydrocarbon.
In this case, the four
carbon butyryl coenzyme A.
In order for the cycle
to repeat itself,
we have to vacate the
ACP, or northern site
on fatty acid synthase,
in order to make
it available for the next
molecule of malonyl CoA
to come in.
That's done by the enzyme, or
subunit, called translocase,
which simply moves the butyryl
group from the northern site
down to the southern site.
The northern sulfhydryl on ACP,
of the fatty acid synthase,
is now available to connect
with the next incoming molecule
of malonyl coenzyme A. The
biosynthetic cycle will now
repeat itself six times in
order to form the 16 carbon long
hydrocarbon, palmitate.
In the figure, its shown
attached to the northern site
of the fatty acid synthase.
Let's look back at the
overall synthesis scheme.
What you'll see is that the
terminal two carbons, that
is the two carbons furthest
to the right in the molecule,
came from acetyl CoA.
But all the other
carbons originally
came from alanyl
coenzyme A. The last step
in the overall reaction
scheme involves thioesterase--
transferring the thioester bound
palmitate to a water molecule,
forming palmitic acid,
which is released.
Now let's turn to storyboard 28.
As I mentioned earlier, the
default length of a fatty acid
is 16 carbons.
That is palmitic acid.
You can look in the
book for pathways
leading to elongation,
desaturation,
and branching of the
parent fatty acid chain.
I'd like to give you, however,
a little bit of detail
on how membrane
lipids are formed,
as well as triacylglycerides.
Let's look at panel A. To
make these higher order
lipids, fatty acids will become
connected to a three carbon
glycerol backbone.
The glycerol
backbone is made from
dihydroxyacetone
phosphate, which
is one of the intermediates
in the glycolytic pathway.
To make the lipid backbone,
dihydroxyacetone phosphate
is reduced by glycerol 3
phosphate dehydrogenase
using NADH as the co-factor.
The product of this reaction
is glycerol 3 phosphate.
An acyltransferase will then
take a fatty acyl coenzyme A
and place it on one
of the hydroxyl groups
of the glycerol backbone to form
a monoacylglyceride phosphate.
Then, as shown in panel B,
a second fatty acid group
will be placed on the
only available hydroxyl
to form a diacylglyceride
phosphate.
This is otherwise known as
a membrane phospholipid.
If the biosynthetic objective
is to make a triacylglyceride,
which is of course our major
storage form of energy,
then a phosphatase will
come in and hydrolyze off
the phosphate from
the three carbon
of the diacylglyceride
phosphate to form
what's called a diacylglycerol.
Then an acyltransferase,
as above,
will place a third fatty acid
onto the glycerol backbone
to form a
triacylglyceride, or TAG.
As I said above, this is
our principal storage form
of energy.